across the country local governments are
releasing thousands of inmates to stop
the spread of the corona virus within
their jails we are looking to release
the inmates that we think are
appropriate releases our population
within their Jail is a vulnerable
population just by virtue of who they
are and where they're located more than
a dozen states including California Ohio
and New York are removing prisoners to
create space and crowded facilities in
New York City Mayor Bill DeBlasio has
coordinated the release of hundreds of
inmates Governor Andrew Cuomo has also
stepped in with plans to release more
than 1,000 inmates of the state 400 of
them in New York City according to the
state's Department of Corrections and
community supervision the city is now
the epicenter for the virus with more
than 45,000 cases in its jails the
corona virus is also spreading quickly
the virus is spreading especially fast
in Rikers Island because of the close
proximity that the prisoners have to one
another they might be sharing a cell or
in a bunk bed or in beds that are placed
close to each other and that's really
what's driving the spread of the disease
there according to the people who work
there the Department of Correction said
that as of Wednesday 353 people had
tested positive for the virus in the
city's jails that's grown from three
cases just two weeks earlier the virus
has killed two department employees so
far they've eliminated outside visits to
the jail they're placing the inmates who
are sick with the virus into a contained
area and they're also trying to practice
social distancing and the use of
protective gear for staff but the virus
continues to spread there at an alarming
rate the board of Correction the
department's oversight agency has sent
multiple letters urging city officials
to release even more inmates it says
officials should prioritize people over
50 years old people with underlying
health conditions people detained for
administrative reasons and people
serving so-called City sentences or
sentences of a year or less dr. Robert
Cohen who has worked for 40 years as a
physician in jails now sits on the board
what will happen to quickly in the jails
if we don't decrease the population
rapidly enough is that people will be
locked down and it will create a
dangerous situation so as many as
possible should be released right now
there are now less than 5,000 people
currently in the city's jail system
while hundreds have already been
released with plans for more the board's
letter identified more than 2,500 people
it says should be considered for release
in order to release the inmates the
mayor the city's District Attorney's a
State Parole Board and the Office of
Criminal Justice which manages the jails
would all have to agree on the release
of these prisoners in October before the
coronavirus the city approved plans to
both close Rikers and cut the number of
people in the city's jails down to 3300
by 2026 Cohen says the board is asking
the city to speed up that plan the time
is not on our side because over time
people staying in the jails are are at
great risk for getting in fact that
Cohen was the director of medical and
mental health services at Rikers Island
when the AIDS epidemic began in 1981 he
was on the board during the h1n1 flu
epidemic and he said he's never seen
anything like this dr. Ross Macdonald
the current chief physician of Rikers
Island also urged the city to release as
many inmates as possible on March 18th
he tweeted we cannot socially distance
dozens of elderly men living in a dorm
sharing a bathroom on this topic de
Blasio told reporters Tuesday that the
jail system which was built a whole
twenty thousand inmates has space Rikers
Island has entire buildings not
currently in use and we're using the
space we have to create some distancing
in general to certainly be able to
isolate anyone who needs to be isolated
purposefully when someone is presenting
symptoms in a New York Jail right now
Department staff informed correctional
health services who then screen that
inmate if clinically indicated the
inmate is then placed in special housing
so-called contagious disease units
eventually staff are saying that that
facility is going to fill up and then
the
the plan is to probably open up
additional buildings on the island for
the housing of these inmates who may
have the virus but the issue is that
these other buildings are decrepit and
they may not have the facilities that
are needed for people to live in them
that's according to city officials I
spoke to and experts on criminal justice
in New York removing people from jails
would be a logistical challenge each
inmate the city decides to release its
considered individually sometimes with
input from multiple officials and that
takes time but it's more than a
logistical challenge for the city trying
to strike this balance between the
humanitarian need to get everyone that
we can get appropriately out of our jail
system out and be mindful that there are
also real public safety concerns here
aside from releasing inmates and
creating space in jails the city has
also taken efforts to stop inmates being
sent to Rikers as they may enter the
jail with the coronavirus there's every
indication that this is an issue that
may become more severe in the coming
weeks and so it's really a multi-faceted
approach to fixing this problem of a
contagion in the city's largest jail
both the city's Department of Correction
and correctional health services said
they were not able to accommodate
interview requests at this time